you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network now this is a
biweekly American history podcast each
week I I user mans of Coates mana no
hairy lip that's a slight Dave Anthony
reads a story from American history to
my friend Gareth Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic will be about is the
mustache can stay the whole show oh yeah
the mustache just got a residency on my
lip Jack it's not your mom doesn't like
it she doesn't need to like it she used
I liked appropriate word which is
rubbish she called it rubbish
well then maybe she's not gonna be a
guest on this show any longer you have
rubbish lip no yeah I have a beautiful
no mustache no Burt Reynolds it does
Gareth right oh man the list goes on and
on man those are manly men yeah are
manly men up until the second one hey on
your face what it's like someone went
pretty little baby uh-huh and put a big
crazy mustache on it I take that as an
enormous compliment like because like a
baby has been your saying for Halloween
as magnum p.i yeah that's a that is an
awesome outfit on a baby it's it's not
if it's permanent it's not if the baby
thinks it's good and real now I think
we're getting into a whole thing about
intelligence of babies which I don't
think is where we want this argument to
get babies you like it
I like it my mother likes it the
American people like it let's go why
don't you shave no it's a non-starter
Jose no just so there's no hair right
here and you guys can go out as like
what is your what it's like a reverse
it's a reverse mo you can do it around
the whiskers just really so you just
have no clue what you're talking about
yeah it's like you've never looked at a
cat take the [ __ ] cat to a groomer
the groomers know how to do a braid
what's not there I need to get my cat D
moustached it's not D mustaches a
reverse mustache oh sorry sorry where's
the menu oh did you go there anything
about fashion uh no locks we had lots of
cats are doing a show a lot of cats are
stylings now you're listening to the
dollar no we did this just play the
intro song I played the intro yeah there
you go
Jesus and this is not gonna come
particularly now hit him with the puppy
you both present sick arguments
what's happening what happened was I
went to turn my phone on to turn down
the sound and then my phone turned off
and then it was like hey put on your
passcode it's not really a nightmare
well you okay but no I'm not a tried you
went on I'm not okay quite a ride you
went on go ahead say your little dates
ah David I will be on the road I'll be
in I'll be at laughs Boston July 19th
through the 20th I'll be at the Denver
improv instead of August 9th through the
11th which were the dates I'll be there
the 26th 27th 28th of July so July 26th
27th 28th I'll be at the Denver improv
instead of in August then I will be at
the Fremont Abbey in Seattle Washington
August 17th then recording an album
comedy on State Street Madison Wisconsin
August 22nd through the 24th 24th I'll
be recording two shows that evening to
attend what are you eating what are you
eating iron yeah what's up bud having
some snack Wells did you not eat
breakfast what's up do you skip it a
meal Oh nobody's doing no are you in
ketosis are you almost in ketosis are
you on the path to ketosis I said no no
I said no he's not what's one of the
things in ketosis is you don't know well
the people fast now people fast not to
hit ketosis ketosis is when your your
body is humming and your your your your
your body is peaking and it's using it
the the intermittent fasting and then
the the nutrients you're adding and the
limited diet it's all of a sudden you're
just working like you're supposed to
work you know it's it's when people are
starving they have something that kicks
in that allows them to keep surviving
for a little bit longer to actually find
food as a amyl and so people act like
it's a good thing when it's actually
saying it's like when you're when
dying of hypothermia you take off your
clothes
that's right I do frizzy - you don't do
frizzy frizzy I do freeze eating I I do
a fast and a hypothermia year I sleep in
the snow huh and as soon as I'm about to
die I have a banana yeah
and then I've never looked better yeah
I've never had more doctors angry at me
yeah yeah they're not except dr. oz he
recommends it take chia seeds we the
dollop podcast we'll be on tour we'll be
in in August we'll be in irvine San
Diego and nope just a friend in San
Diego in September we'll be in San Jose
Sacramento San Jose right well that's up
in the air we're trying to find a new
venue Wow so basically the Irvine to
decide to close you know that San Jose
improv closing for renovations which
affects that that's great thank you for
booking us and then doing that and then
we'll be in October will be in Madison
and Milwaukee and then we head to Europe
November Stockholm Oslo Amsterdam gloves
go Manchester no no pretty good London
what do you think of his accents
Birmingham don't you yeah cordis yeah
it's weird he just kind of makes his
voice hi and thinks that that hope and
Copenhagen oh my god and nailed a people
nailed it that is called the worst
accent store yeah Dave is really gonna
flourish um yeah you guys can say
whatever you want I know well I know I'm
killing it yeah listen say you're uh -
you're a guy okay and and you you had a
a war parade we had tanks and all this
stuff come just a guy the president and
and and why you're having your war
parade you give a speech and you see you
say that there were indeed airports and
in 1776 this is chump no this is just a
guy no
trunk just said this well if you're that
that's the kind of guy you are and
everyone's making fun of you because you
don't know when airports were built for
airplanes 1780 in just in general well I
think you should go get some therapy to
talk through and I think that talk space
is really there probably the best way to
go to find out when airports were made
talk space online therapy makes taking
care of your mental health more
affordable and convenient than ever
before simply provide your preferences
for therapy and talk space will match
with one of 5,000 therapists the very
same day send your therapist unlimited
text audio picture or video message from
anywhere anytime no matter what you're
going through you're not alone you just
be like hey man I said this thing about
airports it's not real it's cool man
don't sweat it too much they weren't
around then but I'm sure you'll be okay
yeah who would why would I mean I feel
like some people saw it and made fun of
me but yeah maybe but that's just
because it's so crazy yeah it is not
great Oh insane it is not great your
go-to it's not great even if the
prompter stopped working it's not great
anyway I'm mad at women's soccer players
look forward to the session tomorrow
it's convenient it's easy to use you can
find the right therapist it doesn't have
to be stressful and it's affordable one
month of therapy on tox based platform
cost about the same as a single
face-to-face session so talk space has
more than 5,000 licensed therapists who
are experienced in addressing the
challenges we all face to match with
your perfect era pused for a fraction of
the price of traditional therapy go to
talk space calm make sure to use a code
dog to get sixty five dollars off your
first month and show you support before
the show that's dollop and talk
space.com we are also brought to you by
Shady raised sunglasses Gareth you enjoy
sunglasses I love I love some sunglasses
David Shady Ray's independent sunglasses
company not some big fancy it's not your
eye right they yes no your ivory tower
say better than everybody else shaped
business we're not
they don't look look down on everybody
else right who's just a classy right
those aren't them the ones you're
looking at new blockers that'll go with
the counseling from before block eater
so the shady raises independent
sunglasses company a little little firm
they got they got great shades far less
than expensive brands which is one of
your favorite things yeah no I love the
dulces the best warranty you you break
them yeah you'll lose them replacements
no matter the cost
you might have them yeah it's good
you're breaking me ilysm what you do you
don't do both that's how they normally
work and here's the great thing about
them when you buy a pair of sunglasses
you get ten free meals to fight hunger
in America with every order so they're
helping feed people which is good
because people shouldn't be starving
which is something we like to do in
America so these guys are trying to help
right there's just so much hair so like
I said replacements if lost or broken
which would haven't your white ones
did you break them the lost are broken
the ones you had the sunglasses you
don't you wore for like two years lost
are broken they are yeah and if you had
used shady Ray's I would have them back
and we wouldn't even be talking like
this look they'll replace some day one
once you lose them or break them check
out all the details on the website and
the warranty and all that good stuff
polarized which is my thing mmm-hmm I
like to see things green certainly on
Twitter it's all that matters to me so
exclusively for our listeners they gave
us the best deal they have to offer this
is a Black Friday a level deal they're
giving us right here use code dollop for
50% off two or more pairs buy one get
one free you can get two bears for $45
wow this is the best deal that
raise offers exclusively for us redeem
only at shader acecomm where you can
find all their newest and best shades
roster brought to you by stamps comm
which I use big fan of stamps calm
basically you go on online you sign up
and then you can do all the services you
can do at the post office right there on
on your computer whether you're a small
office or sending invoices or out online
sellers shipping out products even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
E so you know I got a scale I weigh my
thing I print up how much the postage is
I slap it on and then you know I usually
do thirty or forty packages of time I
put it up front man man comments picked
it up bundled and boom I don't you know
I have to go to the post office anymore
even though I like the post I was she
looks very nice she's my lady I usually
go to at the post office but now I don't
have to go to the food she's a good lady
we've talked about we talked about music
great with stamps economy get five cents
off every first-class stamp and up to
40% off priority a mail so it's no
brainer
you just got do it I'm telling you right
now to do it saves time and money and
you get to have a postman come up and
you get to watch them carry packages
away yeah more so right now our
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus a free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in dollop that
stamps comm enter dollop and Brooklyn in
you like do you sleep in sheets I do you
do your son also your son also uses
sheets when he sleeps which is weird
because he seems the kind of guy that
would sleep just on a mattress with a
mustache before the mustache no just you
you seem like you would sleep a wrapped
in a sheet like a toga that's fair
that's kind of guy you are
I'm not above it and some holly leaves
on your head sure biblical yes well look
we spent a lot of time in sheets 8 hours
a day right you should understand why
not I mean that's a that's that's like a
third of your life yeah so let's let's
do the best thing we can for ourselves
get the best sheets which is Brooklyn
and Brooklyn uns damn a new linen
collection which sounds very nice so I'm
going to colors they have 35,000 plus
five-star reviews more than any other
bedding company they're founded in 2014
by a couple that to get rid of the
middleman who everybody hates the
middleman he's getting screwed yeah I'll
screw that guys in this new economy is a
monster look the job is to make you more
comfortable that's five-star hotel
quality sheets for much much cheaper
prices yeah they're the best and then
they got the new linen pieces that give
your bedroom a chic relaxed feel while
providing you with the ultimate comfort
mm-hmm 12 12 colors in the linens yeah
so look we're big fans of Brooklyn and I
like to sleep on mine and they're soft
and comfortable my wife's a big big fan
Gareth you mostly just have you washed
them in how long have you had them you
don't need to wash Brooklyn and that is
a Miss no not oh it is a there are solar
panels you don't know those I've been
washing those break really easily those
wires do not take suds very well it's in
their name so you know it's good Brooke
linens newest linen collection is
amazing I couldn't recommend their
products more for graduates newlyweds
friends or family or treating yourself
to the better upgrad you deserve
Brooklyn and Comm is giving an exclusive
offer just for our listeners get 10% off
and free shipping when you use promo
code the doll at Brooklyn and calm
Brooklyn is so confident in their
product that all their sheets comforters
and towels come with a lifetime warranty
the only way to get 10% off and free
shipping is to use promo code the dollop
at Brooklyn and Comm that's BR ook Li
and en comm from a code the dollop
Brooklyn and these are the best sheets
ever mmm that is yeah well so much about
the middleman good show the middleman
third great company they inflate the
price they don't do much but they make
it available to you the middleman we're
back
they won't exist I know we should point
out that Pam is wearing earrings given
to us by a fan on an Australian tour Wow
real little hippos or hedgehogs or Oh
mom bats right there well but there are
one that's I think oh no they're those
other things what do you call them
earrings no vodka Oh their quality
caucus oh they might be quiet
yeah I love them every time I wear them
somebody says I love your earrings yeah
a lot of times it's hard to herself but
for you thank you oh yes if we if you
want to watch this this podcast will be
up later in the week on the all things
comedy a YouTube page so you can see how
pretty we all are yeah you can also see
trash tunes there which we'll be
shooting more of which is yeah old timey
cartoons and it's really weird but
people like it I know mother loves it I
love it I think it's really good fifteen
hundred
whoa fifteen hundred squirrels what is
going on mustache is appropriate
squirrels ruled the vast wilderness of
North America Wow
naturalist Ernest Thomas çetin estimated
that at the end of the 15th century when
the first Europeans arrived there could
have been 1 billion
oh my god yeah that's fantastic
yeah they were abundant and ate where
they could that's a lot of squirrels but
life changed for squirrels when European
Connells colonists arrived in the 1600s
that's our people yeah those are mostly
you with a red or gray in them we have
gray and black at the time interesting
but there's a lot of difference with the
Teresa grocery of the grounds grows and
we had flying squirrels sure great yep
and after a while the white man began to
move west and expand from the original
13 qualities squirrels like the Native
Americans
their homeland diminishing mm-hmm before
the colonists there was a balance
between human and animal need for land
resources for centuries Native Americans
cycled the controlled burning of forests
and grasslands to perpetuate an
abundance of nutrient-rich plants which
in turn supported vast numbers of
wildlife what what changed Wow who nor
what to change a natural cycle that was
occurring who saw this perfect
harmonious system they thought we've got
notes tell us the color of the people's
skin's burning helped to increase the
amount of nutrients in the soil so that
plants and grasses could grow thicker
and by burning certain areas repeatedly
Native Americans created sections of
land that grew thick forests around the
perimeter of grasslands as known as the
edge effect yeah so the edge effect
promoted the growth of oak trees which
is the squirrels favorite tree we all
know that mm-hmm I know train a squirrel
it's like yeah yeah Montague and up
Montague
what happened at the beginning it was
good Montague and then well I would say
the other but it wouldn't work because
they don't get along but Montague is the
Montagues those I guess the Montagues
there was a lot of incest now a lot of
people knows but Juliet's parents
brother and sister
what say something Pam re-register Thank
You Junior so so basically Native
Americans use the land is providing the
soil of fresh nutrients which help plant
life and then plants plant any animals
you know and then everything's
flourishing that promotes predators
which keeps everything in balance like
there's a certain there's more of life
when there's more planting animals than
there's more predators when there are
fewer planning animals there's fewer
predators
it all works in
balanced harmonious respectful land-use
mm-hmm let's but not the way the
European saw thing let's have a little
fun let's change it up a little huh the
white man came saw the land and they saw
only one thing dollar signs money cash
capitalism had arrived in America
William croon quote fish fur and lumber
were assigned high values because of
their scarcities in Europe but were more
or less free goods in America so
literally just immediately turn it into
a rummage sale that is why tags on
everything yeah everything must go the
the Native Americans are like look at
this we have this perfect system yeah
right you have a perfect system we could
make a lot of moolah cut those [ __ ]
trees down actually no those trees are
very important to keep here before well
it well it's balanced you see with those
trees that promotes a lot of the
wildlife that comes over here yeah fir
they have fur but we leave them no hats
no no all I'm hearing you say is the
trees help make hats hey what are you
talking to this guy about how great
these hats is gonna be hell yeah hey we
should make a hat out of that guy oh my
god is this the start of the middle man
it might be the middle man's beginning
so right so the white man was so excited
by the possibility of selling all these
things in nature sure that he didn't
actually own right that they and this is
again a white and white guy yeah a white
guys that they entirely neglected the
harmonious cycle created by the Native
Americans they didn't realize there was
so much abundance because of the way
Native Americans had worked with the
land so what I mean I don't know what
they would think they were just like
we're lucky yeah luck his trip we've had
know this [ __ ] this is great there's a
bunch of squirrels here and and land and
we have guns yeah cloning of farmers
used the land until the soil was
depleted of nutrients and then they move
onto a new plot leaving dead land behind
and
cutting down new for us to make meal and
so we just turned it into an Airbnb we
were like really we turned a Four
Seasons into a motel sick right right as
the first dates were settled entire
forests were cut down for towns and
crops of corn and wheat way it's
supposed to be and according to some
people airports and a hundred years
until they make the first Airport to be
fair yeah we're in the 17 yeah go jump
the gun so that's just some people will
get to the airport's okay come on to the
point someone had a really good joke
though they said yeah that's when
LaGuardia was built while that almost
had to find any place to live right
because the crops and the towns are
coming in and they are living in yes
trees and yeah they yes but they also
found an insane overabundance of corn
and wheat fields right so the balance is
gone when you're just planting tons of
corn and wheat and you've gotten rid of
the trees and the other things now
there's more for the squirrels to eat
more corn and wheat you mean for the day
that's just it's just easy right before
they have to go for training and they've
got drive-throughs yeah now that's right
now there's a drive-thru right so for
the squirrels it's like a [ __ ] party
yeah they're not really good at limiting
their intake know there's Kaltura kinte
no squirrels are not those are walking
around being like a week at ketosis
where are we back with it don't they're
not at all I can't we're fasting we've
tried to hit ketosis as a squirrel
family and this all sounds like
squirrels invaded the crops their trees
were gone so they took to the crops
right they became a notorious enemy of
European colonists right as pretty much
everything is when the colonists come
the people that you create a system
where if anything disrupts it their
enemies can you have a system that is
overtaking everything so surely at some
point beings or animals or nature will
infringe upon you
oh yeah because if your cousin if you're
if you're living outside of what nature
wants yeah
then you you are native lighting nature
yes you are just right right and truly a
fight that we will oh it's going good to
the mat 100% right nature you think
you're having if you think you're gonna
have the last laugh you probably will
but we're gonna go down hysterically
we're gonna go down tweeting on lighting
up shoes that have wheels in them so
instead of figure out a way to live with
the squirrel and other animals like the
Native Americans had the colonists
decided the squirrel was the enemy and
it was a pest that needed to be
exterminated completely now I'm fairly
intelligent and even if you're not he's
hitting on us even if you're not and you
see squirrels and just basically what a
squirrel is yeah and you think I'm gonna
exterminate that yes that's like
literally the last the last thing that
are gonna be alive are cockroaches and
squirrels yeah like you cannot they're
called squirrels yeah
just the name alone there's squirrely
yeah it's a hard thing to stamp out
you're saying yeah yeah they get
imported or did you happen we never used
what are their accent English appear
that you're not where's the nuts mate no
other lot name notes weeping that's very
ketosis sir
they used a lot of red but now I think
they've almost oh yeah and they're gray
no we're here the blacks are taking over
story yeah and yours yeah but then they
got wiped out but I think they're come
back but so so so you had native red
squirrels and now the grass course of
when I was young I I don't think I ever
remember seeing a grey squirrel really
another
now you never you never seemed right
it's the why it's like the white man
evasion scrubbers yeah well I'm whiter
so that means you're gonna need to
evacuate this whole area here we're
gonna turn it into a Pinkberry obviously
your red heads need to go so I'll go
yeah the gingers are being yes there
were so many squirrels that the Virginia
House of Burgesses considered laws that
would require Virginians to kill
squirrels that's a law that requires how
do you you have to kill squirrels if
that was in 71 its yeah did you kill it
no well then we're gonna kill you what
yes no yes I knew those of eradicating
didn't imagine the genocide of the
squirrels we're also getting rid of the
squirrels the enablers such as yourself
I just didn't see one well next time you
come back into existence see one went
off with his head
no yes slowly - don't getting him really
saw into it
let's make a lesson out of this oh he
will teach everyone what not to do all I
did was not use word I'll end of the saw
I literally did not see a squirrel
this man has sex when squirrel that's
pretty much our arguments went back then
and now in 1749 we had a break though
yeah
in 1749 authorities in Pennsylvania
offered a three pence bounty for each
squirrel killed same in England now
right it's a lot of money isn't it
yeah back then yeah I'll be off today so
they paid out over 8,000 pounds that
year which equals about 640,000
squirrels okay that's a lot of squirrels
so many squirrels were killed that quote
the state was nearly bankrupt
wow that's quite an investment there
were so many more squirrels out there
and more squirrels were coming in dead
that the state had to cut the bow me do
1 pence per squirrel and then finally
cut it out completely because they had
no money okay yeah but there's too many
[ __ ] squirrels
yeah around the country entire villages
and countryside's would engage in hunts
that became known as a squirrel frolic
[Music]
squirrel orgy yeah
the winner was the person with the most
squirrel tails okay
Kentucky and Michigan newspapers happily
printed up the total number a number of
squirrels killed in 1790 Virginia passed
a law that required every able-bodied
man in certain counties to deliver 12
squirrel tails per year to the local
justice of the peace if they did not
produce 12 squirrel scalps there would
be fine Scotty pence well that's another
that was another worthy detail was a
scallop
yeah right so if you didn't kill a
squirrel a month what happened to you
you would get fined three pence at the
end of the year okay sure sure it's
normal tone almost outwardly normal
stuff and October 1803 and you know
there would be people like me to who
would wait the 12 months happily and
then like with will a week left be like
I gotta kill 12 Spock I procrastinated
oh I would totally dude let me buy a
couple tails off you bro you've got 14
also me about two tails
also what if you didn't have a gun again
do I look like a hammer and try to kill
them well I mean it's probably not a
great look Harry not now in October 1803
Virginia farmers called upon me army to
help them from the squirrels is it
getting pathetic is this now officially
pathetic now that it's an Abbott and
Costello plotline is this now sad
we need the army the Air Force Navy
SEALs Blackwater the squirrels are here
they needed the new president yeah yeah
captain Andrew Fulton assembled his
militia to defend the nmn crops from
hordes of squirrels today we fight the
battle of our lives
is it the British what a No
the Canadians No
smaller face area superior spent more
nuts Oh
Portugal no Mexico why squirrels I'm
sorry little baby squirrels we will
eradicate them they are vermin I know we
will be done with them it's on with some
pause we will kill them all it's like
and we won't have sex with their lives
no yes I don't we will marry squirrels
are they we will take over that's not a
rat on the inside
wait we'll live as squirrels after we've
killed the men what we will live amongst
them pretending to be them at which
point at the eleventh hour we will turn
around and say you fools we were they
are me the entire time
ah yeah now to shrink ourselves to an
80th of our size so just I'm just thrown
out there this is if oh yes volunteer
militia yes and I'm gonna unvoluntary
you no please I'm not I'm not super into
being the tiny squirrel [ __ ] if that's
what I'm hearing you don't need to have
sex with the squirrels we you could have
a marriage with one and make it non
sexual very easily gentlemen we just
need to be in marriages with the women I
don't look I'm already married number
one that's fine this is a fake marriage
number two only your wife will
understand the mission no I don't think
me explain it to this cold-hearted [ __ ]
then she wife doesn't understand okay so
here here's something I'm getting from
all this I think that you have great
idea sexual deviation no you do you're
attractive isn't world know usually
you're trying to get those you do all to
stop hitting yourself stop hitting
yourself stop hitting yourself
yeah you're not in charge you can't be
in charge anymore right now I'm sure
some of you think that I've just a
hundred and fifty squirrels and a man's
skin trying to take over your army we
don't that's ludicrous as well are you
follow me
[Laughter]
I'll see that movie
so captain Fulton divided his men into
hunting parties and they went out one
day and they killed over 8,300 squirrels
which is still but that's like nothing
right no it's absolutely nothing there's
so many squirrels it's almost like when
you shoot a squirrel ten squirrels pop
like it's naturalist Ernest Thompson
Seton quote on Christmas Eve 1807 the
new-born state of Ohio declared war by
passing an act providing the county
taxes in the state might be paid in
squirrel scalps
wait what he's gonna turn it into
currency so yeah I mean essentially you
can pay this money now are we cool do we
as anybody feeling weird because we're
now gonna use this as money this is a
five
these are twenties yes so you can pay
your taxes in squirrel Scouts
uh-huh sure so that accountant was like
by the way I'm done that's normal yeah
so these types of laws spread to other
states like Kentucky and Missouri but
man is no match for the squirrel
naturalist David Garvin's as he traveled
through Ohio in 1820 to quote parts of
the country appeared to swarm with
squirrels which were so numerous that
they might be seen scampering in every
direction the woods and fields might
truly be said to be alive with them yeah
I want to be alive at that time yeah
just squirrels every way and just the
general is like all right guys what we
should do is run up his pant leg bite
his dick let's go no I don't want that
if they're doing it to him and he's like
mm-hmm
the plan no no keep we're still fighting
tried to touch us I'm almost there I'm
reaching ever so slightly
he goes he don't ma'am is yeah he goes
on quote a farmer who had a large field
of Indian corn near the road informed us
that notwithstanding that continued
exertions of himself and his two sons he
feared he should lose a greater part of
his crop in addition to his time and the
expense of a munitions used in killing
and scaring off the little robbers yeah
the man of his sons frequently took
stations in different parts of the field
and killed squirrels until their guns
became too dirty it any longer to be
used was safety yet they always found on
returning that the squirrels had mustard
as strongly as before and keep in mind
the squirrels don't know they're
fighting a war
no the squirrels eat corn
they're brilliant tactician errs of all
I do is eaten [ __ ] what's your war cost
they've just got the instincts we don't
have during this journey we frequently
met squirrel shooters heavy laden with
this game in which many instances they
had only desist from slang from want of
ammunition or through mere fatigue like
it's amazing right I mean they're just
like it's tiring themselves out just
punching body blow after body blow the
squirrels are just like we're just
there's a lot of us I literally cannot
think of a worse thing to try to
exterminate it's white people
[Laughter]
cockroaches
yeah and the more white men came to
America it would be harder to get rid of
em yeah yeah you may as well fight a war
on ant that's right and the more white
men came to America and planted corn and
wheat crops the more squirrels there
were right so they're just creating
their own nightmares so no food they're
just putting out more food right why do
they why do they keep coming you like
the food so the squirrels are the
groundhog and we America are Bill Murray
that's correct right
where
right and the Native Americans just
watching yeah that we had this all
worked out yeah it was actually really
great we're trying to get rid of them
the squirrels know the white man so more
and more squirrels farmers started
having what they call a barbecue they
would get a bunch of young man together
with rifles they would have a squirrel
quota each age man and the men would
also make a wager for who could kill the
most squirrels the farmer would kill and
cook a hog for them Scottish botanist
John Bradley quote there is plenty of
liquor and the frolic ends in shooting
at a mark I have heard of more than
2,000 squirrels being killed at one of
these hunts the squirrels are the
greatest enemy of farmers just to be
clear the order is eat get drunk then go
kill it sounds like it yeah now my
instinct oh yeah go ahead go on the
mission yeah come back have a party to
celebrate after the mission yeah you
don't have the party and then go out on
the drunk mission maybe you don't know
how to party yeah oh there's absolutely
no doubt in my mind the Scottish whiskey
yeah come on
get pissed let's go do the screw cool
lose your legs then we're gonna go kill
him right now they were cheap pistol
bloody well let's go legs go again
it's time for the hunt and after that we
have a party in 1822 the Alexander
Herold in Ohio reported quote it is
impossible to describe the havoc and
destruction of the gray and black
squirrels whole fields of corn five to
ten acres are wholly destroyed not an
ear left in an attempt to save the crops
from total destruction x' hunters
they're killed almost 20,000 squirrels
in a single week Jesus but remember it's
not only not only are they putting out
just like a constant buffet so it's like
Vegas right but then also like Vegas
they remove they've removed all the
Predators there's no one attacking we're
all right right so they've gotten rid of
security and they kept the casino open
that's right and the squirrels are just
in heaven oh my god
in states Alabama Arkansas Georgia
Kentucky Louisiana Mississippi and
Tennessee the goal became the total
eradication of squirrels quite a goal at
the same time the colonists were pushing
Native Americans further west and as
this happened large colonies of gray
squirrels also moved West some migrating
colonies of gray squirrels during the
1800s were said to be over 100 thousand
squirrels and covered hundreds of miles
I mean just imagine seeing that I just
just like I heard I would just pay I pay
so much money to see a hundred thousand
squirrels I mean just like standing
there oh my god yeah yeah in California
the squirrel problem was as bad as
anywhere else except with the ad
addition that here squirrels carry the
bubonic plague yeah we do every one
small people squirrels got the plague
were like yeah let's cross that plague
here yeah okay shoot yeah just shoot
there you go
Wow she's mean you Paulie I'll shoot you
communities came together to gas and
poison squirrels they're gassing
yeah okay I wish I had done the pictures
because there was a great one quote
everyone help the job was finished
followed by a barbecue that's to the
community to come out and they gassed us
for gassim yeah how would you sell their
ground squirrels so your paw alright
putting it into the ground yeah I
imagine it's a mosque yeah yeah they I'm
sure they had gas man my my boys inhale
they're coming
squirrel poisoning crews worked state
lands on March 7th 1876 the Legislature
passed an act that allowed localities to
create squirrel inspectors that is just
a great title what do I do ma'am huh
let's just say I'm a squirrel inspector
I'm out of here
why that's a great job it's got better
Fitz you don't understand up port my
workers squirrel inspectors made sure
landowners were killing squirrels on
their land
guys they yeah in housing in squirrels
in main house is you you were you got a
little little fellas around here run
around Matt I trouble you for a glass of
milk are you this gross vector or the
odor that's a reach that's an inglorious
basterds reference yeah never thought I
tried I could get through it don't like
I call that one table talk about a
little movie this is conversations over
a table
what about not if they if so if
landowners are not killing squirrels the
squirrel inspector comes he gives them a
deadline to kill their squirrels and if
they don't then he has a squirrels
killed and then charges the owner for
how much it cost of the school how do
you know like how many slake squirrels
are mobile so they're like well he's a
he's a he's a screw inspector this is
his job but he can't but just like we're
saying like this is like fingers in a
dam like theirs they will they're always
going to be there so you could feasibly
be like yeah I killed all of them and
then he's like why the early squirrels
you cuz there's a lot of squirrels here
yes so there's a there's an issue with
the okay inspectors just a lot of like
bravado essentially they're I did all
matter be killing him I definitely read
a lot of articles about newspapers and
there were some really yeah there's
there's crow inspectors that were just
like there's tons of squirrels on this
property
there's tons of squirrels everywhere and
I keep legs did used to be like he's
allowing squirrels to burrow its land
and the guys like what do you mean crazy
Jack I'll handle this [ __ ] squirrel
yes he's winking towards waking have you
ever treated dogs with so it's a
squirrel way so that's what this is it's
a squirrel whistle I can't kill all the
squirrels do you know not with that
attitude cuz they're squirrels yeah
exactly
today enables them their step you know
what we should do what get really drunk
is a viable option
we'll hit him with logs so in California
the squirrel problem was as bad as
anywhere else except what the alligator
said already did that so scroll
inspectors they come they kill blah blah
blah sure are you giving me the tagline
for the TV show yeah in August 1914
World War one broke out across Europe
but the US was looking to stay out
President Wilson said he would remain
neutral and Americans were down with no
involvement they didn't want to we were
like yeah it doesn't seem that great the
public opinion changed after the Germans
sunk the British ocean liner Lusitania
in 1915 128 Americans died and then
2,000 other blah blah blah sure it's how
Americans yeah 128 of us are gone
a lot of people died about that part
there was a threat of alliance between
Germany and Mexico so Wilson ends up
asking Congress for a declaration of war
and we enter the war on April 6 re 19th
declaration of war war yeah we used to
do that we used to what but we used to
go to Congress and ask Congress yeah
it's the Congress so Congress yeah
Congress this thing who and you would
say I declare war and you would need to
have it absolutely approve it yeah so
you're not like a king just making
decision oh now where you can just hum
fight wars we mean we're not fighting a
war I mean seven no we're not fighting
anyone no no we are no right bombing
people is not war sorry I am the one who
keeps getting caught up on well yeah
yeah yeah right you just bomb about your
[ __ ] that's that's not war right so you
don't need a declaration for that cuz
all bombing countries as opposed to war
when you're bombing countries okay
gotcha okay thank you thank you
the war would entirely change US food
infrastructure in the u.s. the food
supply was so plentiful that when the
war broke out we were the biggest
supplier of food relief in the world aid
was sent to France and Belgium but then
when we joined the war the American
primary concern became feeding our own
troops and because they're Americans we
want to feed them super well wait
goddamn minute no it's not that's not it
should be but it's not work okay how you
boys like on that beef I mean we really
should have tiny bones in this cow yeah
a typical daily ration for us
infantryman was up to 5,000 calories
from a pound of meat preferably not
canned 20 ounces of potatoes and 18
ounces of bread this was 20% more than
the French or British could supply their
men and way more than the Germans
because of this us housewives were told
to be patriotic and that they should
mind their pantry keep down food waste
and go without grain okay so quote the
boys over there could be fed and this
led to conservation in the birth of
advertising
oh no president no some what a horrible
thing President Wilson created the US
Food Administration mining executive
Herbert Hoover was made director Hoover
became known as America's food dictator
good good so we need that is good it's
Gordon Ramsay the usf a mix affixed the
price of wheat took over rail lines to
improve transportation and prevented
food monopolies okay and so to push
support for the war Wilson created the
Committee on Public Information which is
a propaganda Factory okay good
CPI cranked out press releases and
informational pamphlets they deployed
around 75,000 for Minutemen who are
public speakers okay so these people
these people would show up in parks
churches social gatherings vaudeville
theaters and give quick four minute
lectures for a quick lecture to get
people fired up about the war three they
the lectures yeah he's at four minutes
about 7.5 million speeches were given in
a year and a half some of them of course
were about food okay which you love you
love food yeah I find it important
so campaigns were created like meatless
Mondays Wow local is best eat less wheat
Jesus
yeah very great thoughts I know when you
think about this you're like Oh meatless
Mondays yeah we should be doing that now
well actually you know I think when we
were going to some of those climate
change things the way that they would
talk about what is happening how it has
to be a world war ii type effort like
all they're talking about
yeah like because it does need like it
was there were certain times where the
country was united because for the
greater good of the country that's just
something that happened yeah and that
that's exactly what when people say we
need a world war two times yeah yeah
it's where you're just like all hands on
deck everybody is a part of yeah
figuring this out and we are doing it
that's right here they are giving all
will you send them wheat yeah they're
giving this a poster of soldiers and
says they're giving their all will you
something is the she's holding a big key
to victory eat less bread man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you me mom my [ __ ] you're like me
yeah okay so uh so this is all being
done through the US Food Administration
also anything German was vilified
sauerkraut became Liberty cabbage
hamburgers became Liberty steaks and
then we did all that [ __ ] again with
freedom yeah of course we did we're very
good at this
the CPI cranked out at fifteen hundred
posters and buttons USFA created so much
art that it filled more than 19 million
dollars worth of donated advertising
space the main message quote food will
win the war waste nothing yeah this need
to produce food led to fighting an old
foe at home oh no the squirrel in the
summer of 1970 teen papers began
reporting on the danger of squirrels the
danger of squirrels the Oakland because
I guess it over time it had been
forgotten because of the advancement
agriculture and everything we were doing
and so
the actual threat of squirrels sort of
faded away right there's still a past
the farmers still know but they're like
okay yeah [ __ ] squirrels right an
Oakland Tribune article on July 8th read
this is the headline squirrels are
enemy's allies danger to food supply our
enemy's allies so squirrels are working
in in league with the German essentially
they are in conjunction with the Germans
coming after us quote the ravages of the
ground squirrel and Gophers must be
checked the California ground squirrel
stands first today as an undisputed ally
of the country's enemies every day he is
working most industriously to destroy
large quantities of the food products of
the state of California okay so let's
win this war that we've been unable to
win the whole time that's right
the article went on to say the farmers
were important defenders of the country
okay quote it is an act of defense to
prevent the deviation of large
quantities of food from the mouths of
the soldier to the greedy jaws and sharp
teeth of the ground squirrel meanwhile
they're just like we're squirrels greedy
jaws look at the beady little eyes
we're just swirl eyelid squirrel your
squirrels we're from trees I like we I'm
underground now look at them the
brilliant planning the German said
squirrels they always in here they've
always been here where the tree now we
like nuts the article in ours so the
California State horticulture
commissioner horticultural commissioner
here GH heck announced that pests mainly
the ground squirrel we're destroying
anywhere between five to twenty five
percent of the state's grain crop is
that true yes Wow
twenty five percent yes I mean they were
like they're [ __ ] genuinely like
smoking at this point you know what I
mean I gotta tell you I'm pretty much
over working like that I'm done with I'm
retiring it to I really am
so he commissioned the Commissioner said
he was enlisting the support of county
boards of Supervisors and County
Council's of defense to combat squirrels
now there's horticultural commissioners
in every County it's like a so this is a
movement it's a movement this was to be
a statewide campaign to eradicate
squirrels okay and again 1917 an
impossible mission well you'll see no I
have seen there's no more squirrels no
no no you haven't seen it's grown no I
have not in your life yes I have the
California Legislature agreed and passed
a law providing for the destruction of
squirrels and noxious weeds and noxious
weed ruin some weeds that guy just
showed up that's right squirrels and the
noxious weeds Harry what are you doing
I'm just saying that we gotta get rid of
these bad weeds I did get paid by
Monsanto what are you talking about
come on get sweet come on we got to get
rid of these swirls they're killing
everyone plus some people are saying
these nuts just weeds is a big problem
to a lot of my constituent azar saying
such saying the squirrels in the noxious
weeds talk they got a team that's that
team it up little jackets made the
legislature also passed a law against
harboring squirrels that's the craziest
it's just the craziest like people look
like you just be like yeah it's a
squirrel what's it doing in your place
it got in ah so you admit it it became
it was a misdemeanor and punishable by a
500 or fine or six months in jail what
are you in for it
squirrel Sam crazy man I just fell in
love with this little guy I made a
little half yeah it looks so great and
glows awesome plus they're so fat now
you can watch them so easy like grabbing
a hair my guy can't even his feet don't
even touch the girl that's the profits
what I was trying to say to the
inspector he can't leave he can't get
through the door he's too big great
great little guys yeah
hell yeah the play the the Harold quote
the question now is a matter of whether
you will do it or leave it to the
official exterminator to do the
squirrels must go where squirrels do you
think they've noticed the drop in their
numbers well unfortunately commander
they are squirrels we don't know what
they're thinking oh and November the
California rodent control division
released a 200 page report tighter
titled California ground squirrels so is
this now like in a movie where it's like
the police and the FBI show up and it's
like this is our case now yeah but it's
like now you've got like we're rodent
control you guys can't seem to handle
this and send the big boys and they're
doing all this propaganda right the
answer to this is leaflets we're
dropping these all around squirrel
communities letting them know the
bulletins dealing with the life
histories and habits and control of
ground squirrels in California so that's
what it was it's 200 pages it's I read
some of it
a lot of it's just different kinds of
ground squirrels and then it goes an
attic you'll just gotta read this dense
thing before all right I think I know
every kind and all about squirrels now
right
not a eradicated they described the many
different types of ground squirrels in
California as well as ways to kill them
on November 21st 1917 the two-layer
Advanced Register reported cryptically
quote county commissioner roll yard of
fresno has discontinued for the time
being for squirrel inspectors and a
deputy having to do with the squirrel
campaign wait they're done with them
they they fired him they fire them this
is because of certain private interests
being advanced at the expense of the
county we work with big squirrel hey
what are you guys doing here inspector
we just wanna have a word with you I'm
out here trying to find a bunch of
squirrels well we've always loved your
commitment that's why I want to talk to
you we represent the squirrels we're
squirrel lawyers hey Bobby you working
with the squirrels what's in your pocket
huh nothing
look away Tim are those squirrels no
it's nothing why your pants moving look
I made a move I had to make for my
family you won't have a big squirrel
they have great ideas
and they pay unbelievable how much less
how much less the thing they told me
yeah there's no goddamn way we'll ever
get rid of all the squirrels come on no
so it's stupid are you [ __ ] kidding
me no we're gonna we're gonna kill these
bass no it's easy there's billions wait
no I gave hundred the term they're
breeding like squirrels oh yeah well
that's a term I don't think it is it's a
saying it not a word a phrase it's not
either that is no way to pop lyric it's
there's no such thing
look I gotta go are you a time traveler
I yes what is hip hop so in December it
was announced the state was giving
40,000 to horticultural commissioner
heck for the extermination of ground
squirrels okay a plan was then
formulated sure which we haven't seen
yet we have not no we have like eight
times right yeah a lot in March a
convention of state horticultural
commissioners was held in Fresno
okay they discussed and laid out the
plans for the squirrel eradication
campaign which was to begin on April
12th 1918 it would be called no squirrel
we took you my family what do you guys
do someone dresses up like the squirrel
did you do it you put a bunch of
presents and nuts yeah we have a tree
yeah you hide a mystery and we have a
little squirrel hostages yeah hostages
whoever eats the most cashews in their
mouth gets as a squirrel pillow a
squirrel pillow yeah this all sounds
made-up that's crazy
yeah
and it's almost under stocking yeah
that's Christmas doc I mean yeah don't
mess up so to show oh my god no yeah
this is to show how behind the plan they
were the commissioners will get there
the commissioners Eights dude Mendocino
County [ __ ] gopher okay the grain-fed
Gophers were served to show the
possibilities of meat supply in the
state okay I was thinking like that to
me would be right that's how that would
be a way that can was yes that's a way
to propagandize people but easily but
they'll burgers yeah they did that a
little bit but not that also gopher it's
like a jerky burger Commissioner Howard
said it tasted like wild duck and that
it was quote not half bad well and that
that's the man who's supposed to be
lying to you you're saying it's not half
so it's probably really not good bad
yeah it's all bad yeah yes it's not good
though the SF Chronicle reported quote
liberal portions of beef were served to
those who did not like the Gopher meat
liberal portions yeah hey can we get
some beef in here this is [ __ ] this
tastes like an animal's been living in a
hole give him what gopher here's some
gopher no I don't want the head I've got
a piece of fur in my mouth yeah yeah
these have not been very forage squirrel
week was to be a seven-day squirrel
killing competition during which oh here
we go
California children were encouraged to
kill off the state's ground squirrels
newspapers repeatedly declared that
squirrels were destroying 30 million
dollars worth of crops a year in the
state which is about 550 million today
the patriotism and help in fighting
Germany was emphasized of course I mean
the tions obvious heck quote we have
enemies here at home more destructive
perhaps then some of the enemies our
boys are fighting in the trenches it's
absolutely right absolutely right I'm
tired squirrels boy
that's right defending sure yeah yeah
your pops over there get mustard gas and
whatnot yeah but what about this
squirrel seems less bad little tiny
animals eating little tiny pieces of
wheat when you put it like that it
really seems like a leave and when they
kill our bread what do they kill it's
been mean what you said about my dad in
the trenches why is he why is it about
my dad because the squirrels are killing
your father son eat your Gopher boys
less that question question more
choo-choo-choo-choo choo-choo-choo-choo
tomorrow we'll cook them for you all
right so now even children could fight
the Germans heck called the kids school
soldiers yeah that's good well by the
way we're pretty much there again aren't
we yep he encouraged kids to do their
part for Uncle Sam by organizing quote a
company of soldiers in your class or in
your school and destroy the quote
squirrel army what we're looking for our
children based malicious that's not
dangerous right let's just do that and
let's arm them the state began an anti
squirrel publicity blitz 34,000 posters
were printed up and put up around the
state and 50,000 leaflets were
distributed Hex call to arms was written
in a pamphlet called kill the squirrels
oh Jesus Christ
the pen was insane the pamphlets cover
this guy think I had the part of talking
to the squirrels
yeah she's got poison barley like with a
child stick [ __ ] take this poison
barley okay ma'am
so the pamphlets cover illustration
included a young woman holding a pail of
poison barley saying it kids around
air-quote children who must kill the
squirrels to save food but use poisons
carefully ah use poisons care to a child
and then below there's some weird dude
with the squirrels
and he goes and you may have to serve me
some of that nice young barley sprouts
which has been poisoned yeah he's a
waiter a long life off of our land the
opening sentence in the pamphlet quote
is they're one of our number who would
like to be a member of a company made up
of American boys and girls fighting to
protect our big brother or cousin at the
front in Europe we have enemies here at
home more destructive perhaps than some
of the enemies our boys are fighting in
the trenches that's insane
mmm trying to get the kids so the kids
you know their kids and their there's a
war on and a lot of their dads are off
fighting and so they want to be a part
of it so you're just tugging on this
emotional the manipulation yeah yeah
there was a recipe to make strychnine
laced grain should a child be that they
said to be careful sure I took part of
it so 16 quarts of barley 1 ounce of
strychnine one first two ingredients
really say all do you want to do one
part strychnine for every 16 parts
barley in case you're making a big cake
or something fortunately there was a
warning to keep all poison containers
and utensils used in preparation and
preparing the poison to be plainly
labeled and out of reach of
irresponsible person lives yes yes just
like guns and pills that's the great
school bake-off that's right yeah oh yes
also children should be cautioned in the
use of poison barley they said yeah no
for sure
you gonna here's a bunch of poison now
guys don't abuse this that's right just
go willy-nilly toss it all over land
trying to kill squirrels the pamphlet
also described other squirrel killing
methods like shooting poison gas and
drowning them which they called
submarining
great great great great awesome heck
offered $50.00 to each elementary school
whose students killed the most squirrels
second place 30 and third place 20 and
then the same offer went to high schools
the pamphlet ended with a warning quote
remember that poison grain is dangerous
to handle and be careful in using it let
us make these squirrels less days that's
right don't forget poisons really poison
good luck children
[Music]
all right toddlers you've got your
walking orders propaganda was cranked
out just as was for the war effort right
so you've got this war effort on it
you've got this giant organization made
to create propaganda so they started
making anti scroll propaganda what else
- the crops kill them oh that came back
to the same page so this so they're just
cranking out all these posters that are
all about well this is probably around
the time right when they realize the
power of you know not only influence but
like pamphlets well it's like that was
just like all of a sudden like pamphlets
posters up you want yeah a big poster
mr. farmer join in the great spring
drive now on 30,000 annual losses and
then there's a little picture of a
squirrel with a German the German helmet
he's eating up your money the law says
kill him in the corners of the kill I
just wish squirrels knew that they won
the war yeah that they didn't know was I
had no idea in the corners of the kill
the squirrels cover illustration -
squirrels sort attention wearing pickin
haben which were the spiked helmets of
the German army so this became very
common putting a squirrels in German
German army another squirrel League
poster showed a germanic squirrel family
wearing spiked helmets and iron crosses
the father squirrel had an upturned
mustache just like Kaiser Wilhelm's
these papers got kids all fired up
here's another one
death to the squirrel the spring drive
is on million millions in food must be
saved the squirrel in time saves killing
9 a squirrel at times killing I'll get
to why that isn't a sec newspapers got
kids fired up the Lompoc Journal wrote
excitedly that quote all the killing
devices of modern warfare will be used
in the effort to annihilate the squirrel
army including gas don't wait to be
drafted so they literally like there's
literally all these men being horribly
killed and and their their lives [ __ ]
by mustard gas and they're using that as
right rationale for gassing the
squirrels getting kids excited about it
the four-minute man jumped into the
propaganda push him again give him
speeches to get the public fired up for
the squirrel genocide talking points
were given to the four-minute man
including the best squirrel is a dead
squirrel mm-hmm the Hotel California
board
bill for ground squirrels in 1917 was
30,000 yet unpaid the squirrel does not
recognize daylight saving he uses it all
so dumb why hesitate we can get him how
poison them gassim drown them shoot him
trap him in submarine 'im are you not
willing to give your wholehearted
support to this statewide movement to
kill the squirrel nope
also go out and kill the little ally of
the Kaiser whose idea on squirrel war
I just like we I'm a squirrel he's
brilliant he's got such a brilliant
military mind meetings are also held in
many chambers of commerce around the
state in Salinas the local horticulture
commissioner and a professor discuss
squirrels farmers were told that spring
was the time to kill squirrels before
they had their babies each female
squirrel averaged eight babies so
killing a female in the spring was as
good as killing nine squirrels right so
a squirrel in time saves killing nine
slay the mother and one farmer neglected
his squirrel killing duties would undo
all the killing efforts of
neighbors that's right yeah it's a
turning neighbor versus neighbor totally
so that's like keeping an eye on you
kill your squirrels Jimmy yeah why are
you asking I just worried about you I
ain't seen you killing a lot of
squirrels on your pillow what am I
supposed to do they're probably telling
each tailed squirrels I might send it
over to your side cuz you're my feed
annoyed yeah Jim inseminate me shake you
support the Kaiser squirrel you probably
got a bunch of little helmets in there
Dungy put him on him huh see chef
frickin weirdo you shut your goddamn
shut your goddamn mouth you're the one
who came over here accusing me of
holding squirrels all I do is kill
squirrels moms too bro killing all the
moms what'd I do what'd I let him have a
babies and then I kill the babies right
in front of them on a foolhardy cuz one
of the babies could probably it away not
from me mother well it's still dangerous
to do it like that if you read the
pamphlets they say don't do it like that
kill the mom right away but you're
waiting months for birth what are you
some sort of sick bastard where'd you
get a mustache huh why don't you grow a
mustache it's morning
it's a squirrel you know I suppose a
mustache yeah yeah yeah yeah let's see
it's 6:00 p.m.
yep four bye I love thank you sometimes
just don't know how to end a sketch
mm-hmm the children were told to verify
their kills by bringing squirrel tail
tails to their schools by the way if
you're a counterfeit tail maker this is
the best time but some eager kids got
the jump early and look for credit a
week before squirrel week was due to
begin Commissioner hex Office asked kids
to stop sending dead squirrel tails to
his office Oh San Francisco Chronicle
quote because of the pronounced odor
which has begun to permeate the offices
of the state of a horticulture
Commission as a result of the
accumulation of ground squirrel tails
being sent as evidence commissioner heck
issued instructions to County
Commissioners to receive the tails and
bury them right yeah
instead of having him in his office
that's nice just interesting how many
yeah yeah just get rid of him yeah that
makes sense too anyway I'm gonna handle
it he said would be fine for children to
just give the kids credit for tales
delivered and setting that to his office
instead okay on April 29th the day the
campaign started her Herbert Hoover told
the state's children quote I understand
you are taking up a campaign for the
eradication of ground squirrels in
California this has my hearty approval
cool mr. president thank you and the
killing began the Visalia Times reported
that the rodent control division
indicated widespread activity among
school children the Chino champion
newspaper said everyone must be involved
quote if your neighbor is not doing his
duty report him this wasn't just the
paper saying this the Kings County
horticulture commissioner said quote
anyone knowing of cases where no attempt
has been made to kill the squirrels as
has been asked by the government report
him crazy and it's also like they
probably like we're making a dent no
you're not it's like it sounds like how
we deal with terrorism ya know we're
fighting ghosts
it totally yeah the commissioner said
people who don't kill squirrels were
quote no better than a slacker and such
persons will be dealt with accordingly
yeah what are you gonna do
they will be dealt with I'm gonna shut
the door your sir yeah very much trouble
so please start no you're going to get a
squirrel lecture banging one of the four
minute fellas okay sure
you're ready for this you son of a [ __ ]
yeah I guess what are you squirrel
loving [ __ ] somebody's gonna
talk for four minutes how dare you I'm
just sayin four minutes
it's gonna be easy it's not gonna be
easy
okay he's get squirrel talking points
great I really just am like I don't
think it's gonna make a difference so
I'm kind of just gonna take a knee on
this taking me
I'm out I'm not doing it buddy yeah
we're fighting squirrels here yeah I
understand the enemy yeah it seems a
little crazy have you seen the German
helmets yeah I think so what's up German
helmets no I think though they started
wearing and I think that's just
something that a guy drew No
yeah he drew that base on a on a on a
actual squirrel sighting so someone said
they saw a squirrel with a helmet on
didn't see a druid because he's old the
[ __ ] does that mean what are you a kid I
mean if you believe that yeah I got a
bridge I'll sell you people you should
be out over there with those school kids
trying to kill squirrels yes six year
old let me just say what it's your de
nieve atte that's gonna lose this war
yeah no I think we can win the war I got
killing the squirrels the Allies of the
German I see I give you you're
conflating things they made a pact who
did the Germans on the squirrels
yeah the King squirrel where did they
meet will home Wilhelm
he went to the squirrel Shire he went to
the squirrels SHhhh I had a meeting so
why don't you just go to the squirrel
Shire and blow it up if there's such a
thing oh you're so [ __ ] stupid
I'm not even waiting for this
four-minute guy to show up knock what
he's here I'm the food this is part of
the four minutes brutal that's what I
thought I'll kill some just take it in
[Music]
it's a scroll week ended on May 4th it
had been I like to celebrate year round
we do in our family we celebrate have
been an incredible success ok children
across the state turned in a hundred
thousand for a five hundred and nine
tails ok pretty good this number was
believed to be just a fraction of the
total squirrel casualties because many
were killed by gas in their burrows and
they could not be counted sure and kids
were so into it after the contest ended
heck reported that kids enthusiasm for
killing squirrels continued for quote an
indefinite period that's great that they
sell the blood thirst once you get it
once kill white squirrel you're like
this is awesome well once you've just
given your kids the green light to go
gas animals you're pretty much being
like the world's your oyster so there
really is nothing better than gassing an
animal now for sure have you ever done
it it is here
that's Proclamation squirrel week I do
here
by set aside the week of April 29th to
play as the ground squirrel week and
trust that during that time the school
children and all other persons will do
their utmost to relieve the country of
all ground squirrel pests and there's
three squirrels watching mm-hmm huh
that's not a good Proclamation this is
[ __ ] it really was a campaign huh
yeah no it's really it's really crazy
oh yeah that's all me just like that so
oh this is a good one oh no that was a
different so this is the way thing is
they're all dead all their other
campaigns sort of look alike it's all
propaganda posters whatever now we're
getting to German stuff mmm Paris where
so there's a lot a lot of art went into
this ya know it's important killed the
squirrels food is neither for our allies
yeah and June the winners were announced
sulfur banks Grammar School in Lake
County won first prize
David Creek Grammar School in a Modoc
County won second prize and Delta V
Grammar School in kins Kings County one
third also squirrel you terribly some
schools rounded as total failures in
Oxnard the Oxnard Korea reported that
Santa Paula High School reported only
three squirrels killed what were they
doing [ __ ] they're near the beach was to
kill students no you idiots
squirrels god damn it how many kids are
left five the paper reported other high
schools in the area had killed none
quote the grammar schools were a little
better the grammar schools or they're
not yeah I know they're not that
patriotic and yeah they don't love
America so it was a sick it was
considered a success farmers became more
aware of the squirrel Menace crop yields
bounced back in areas cleared out of
ground squirrels Wow okay so hey I don't
work yeah heck congratulate the children
for their successful slaughter and
patriotic service he also urged them to
take every opportunity the feed
not to kill in the future not one to
kill the squirrel but other rodents as
well so feel free to kill any animal oh
yeah any road get on it
squirrel inspectors remained active
oakdale squirrel inspector Frank Knott
said property owners along local canals
we're not getting rid of the squirrels
and that he had to send them notices
that if they failed to get rid of them
he would take care of it and the fee he
would assess against the property which
now could be sold to pay for squirrel
eradication you could now yes because
somebody had not taken a full-throttle
approach to the squirrel genocide that's
correct you could now go ahead and sell
their home and take that money and use
that as financing for the cause give
good anti squirrel cause you could see
where's your home that's a long story
bad local areas continued to hold
children squirrel killing contests and
now there were local contests during an
anti squirrel campaign in lassen County
later in 1918 one girl brought in three
thousand seven hundred eighty tails and
abroad boy brought it in 3717 an eighth
grade I mean they're killing it an adult
level an eighth grade girl who killed so
many squirrels that she was allowed to
take part in the essay contest so there
was an essay contest but the only way to
get an essay contest was to enter it by
having enough tails right so right
perfect make sense interesa
the squirrel is about the most
destructive animal in California if you
would only stop for a moment and compare
a squirrel with a German soldier you
would find them very much alike do you
think that do you think that the
propaganda has worked on this young girl
oh my god we were like what a great
essay where'd you come up with such a
great idea I don't know but it's what I
feel so the squirrel killing continued
and Skrill eradication programs
continued until the 40s and when they
started to wane off just not 11 where
children were turned into you know
squirrel murders world massacres a
squirrel is still considered a pest by
farmers today sure Jesus do you have any
idea about that I know I do know believe
it I like squirrels I do too
you know I actually I heard that people
from countries that don't have squirrels
get extremely freaked out by them really
yeah I one time in the common in Boston
I was just sitting there having lunch
and a squirrel just ran up on my knee
just sat there for like five minutes
just like that means people feed it you
know means that I made a friend and and
by the way in the common that make makes
sense but I I it is it always amazes me
that the we can look at population
control for any other species of
anything besides our own like yeah I
know that we look at any any I mean
there are like in Wisconsin where you
know where we live like it would be deer
like you'd be like yeah you have to keep
the deer population out it's not not
true like it is true you do but mostly
there is also this one species of animal
that needs to have its population
controlled in Vick to the enth degree
and we just sit around we ignore that
well yeah
now that but it's like how I mean if
you're gonna like if you're talking I'll
tell you what you need to start a
campaign or children to kill adults
that's what we need they've they're very
old
yes very old people well some excluded
definitely well-liked
I mean modern agriculture is it keeps
people alive but also allows us to keep
making people yeah and very back in the
old days you would have a
yeah and it it's it's same thing with
deer like there's too many deer they
have a famine and it calls the
population or they gets to get a
sickness there's like you're carrying
capacity and no but there now we there
we allow that to take place in any other
part of nature except for our own that's
right and it is yeah it's what I call a
problem and now we create pills to keep
everybody alive yeah no that's true I
mean like you just there are too many I
mean there are there are many too well
my grandmother people there's too many
new people school the new people my
grandmother you yeah my grandma was 96
and I went to see her in the hospital
and she's like I'm done I just don't
know what do you mean she goes she goes
I don't want to live anymore it's it and
I go don't you want to see like me have
a grandkid and she cuz I I Met Your Wife
and guess what I've seen a bunch of
babies and I know how it all goes and
that's great I'm really happy for you
she goes but I'm just like I've done
this yeah and I've done it all and now
I'm in paying a lot and I you know yes
is in a fun safe I can't get around
people people I mean the level of like
honest to god at some point we need to
bring the Duggars up on a war crime
who's having like teen number like if
you're if you if your family is starts
with 20 it's like if that's the amount
of kids you have starts at 20 you you
need you need to be submarined yeah like
a it's yeah it's really yeah it's bad
and those people are doing it for the
reason of yes biblical yes right they
want to take over oh the Lord said
cometh cometh then my wife until she
half a barren woman
finish her more stackin treat him like
pancakes in a belly one on top of the
other
I think the main moral of this is
man keeps trying to conquer nature and
it keeps not working it's also a beaut
it's a lit is that story in particular
is hilarious because the one side
doesn't know there's a war then there's
one that's right they won there's
nothing like in the annals of squirrel
history they're like inside a tree like
that was close they're just like we're
squirrels we're still squirrels provides
but squirrels we eat these don't eat
those doesn't berries you were squirrels
yeah we're pretty [ __ ] up yeah but
like are you saying you'll be okay we
are gonna be okay we don't need to do
anything differently do what you're
doing regularly
it'll be fine it's so hard for people to
wrap their heads around the fact that
modern society is structured around not
not just not just like the production of
carbon in the atmosphere but our entire
way we are structured
there's soils is dying like we don't
soil the way we use it we're killing the
soil we're literally not gonna be able
to feed people in the near future yes
and and it's a big issue of it
and a lot of that is because what we
talked about just coming in destroying
land farming it till it's dead and then
moving on that's that's why the Amazon
is getting knocked down because you
knock down the Amazon you plant crops
they don't last that long
knocked out more Amazon no it's not it's
pretty straightforward that
precipitation is key and we are finding
every way we can to get [ __ ] rid of
it yeah it's pretty good yeah it'll be
good anyway things are fine we did turn
the squirrels story in to a climate
change talk and we did it we did it